let me ask you the final question okay
can you tell me a time in your life that
you laughed really really really really
hard
Maybe
you were on drugs maybe someone farted
maybe someone fell down these are the
these are the options oh I have one this
is I yeah
okay so I'll try to make this quick so I
was in high school and my well not two
of my best friends Sam and Jess
uh we were volunteering
um
it's like Halloween and we were
volunteering to scare kids on like a
trail
like I don't know why it was like they
like needed people to like there was
like a like a Haunted Trail in like this
like Community Center they like needed
people to like volunteer to like be the
people that like scared people anyway we
were doing that and then we also
simultaneously were teens and we're like
there's a party tonight we need to leave
and so we'd committed to volunteering
and then we're sneaking out also like
what were we volunteering it wasn't like
a charity it was like a scare kids yeah
a scare group anyway so we were like we
gotta sneak out of this Trail to go to
the party we really wanted to go to high
schools
we had like masks and wigs and I think
we were going to my house after to
change anyway so we're running away from
the trail like trying to be
like Sly about it and we finally I was
in the front because I was pretty fast I
was in the front and we were like it was
like from Trail into parking lot like
pavement change like so like the like
blacktop of the of the parking lot like
was like a dip in the yes anyway
sprinting we're like looking back and
like we made it we made it I
trip over the like pavement go down so
hard okay like like like full like down
on the pavement and Jess is right on my
tail
and so she she falls on over me like
trips on me and then Sam like made it
out clear but we were we were dying like
because we'd been trying to get away
quietly and quickly and truly like hurt
ourselves so much leaving this volunteer
like Halloween like it was nuts and like
really hurt ourselves and it was one of
those moments as a teenager where I've
never laughed harder oh
and like like
blood like blood like skinned like hurt
every which was very fitting for the
holiday yeah you looked even scarier it
was so messy and you had a wig on it was
like that makes it yeah it was like like
I think I I think I would had a mask so
I like took the mask off but like we
were carrying like the that we had
like dressed up as yeah it was so messy
wow yeah
I love that that's what I'm going to
remember it also reminded me of a bed I
used to have where I was like a lot of
people get hit by cars on Halloween
which is obviously sad and it also has
to be awkward too because for a moment
you're like either they're really hurt
or that's a great costume
great like in action costume my God
yeah yeah
wow that looks uh it looks so real
quick
[Music]